[Music]
hello and welcome back to
chessopenings.com Denby and today our
big topic is going to be about a certain
chess player by the name of Hikaru
Nakamura
and now Hikaru has been doing something
really interesting lately in a series of
online rapid and blitz tournaments that
he's taken part in and that thing is
he's repeating the same opening line
against one d4 and specifically the
queen's gambit and he's playing this
line over and over again with pretty
mixed results he's had a couple
unfortunate losses a couple really nice
draws and I don't think he's won too
many games with this opening but it's
less of a super combative trying to win
out in the Queens gambit declined and
more of just a solid way to get to a
equal position that he should be able to
hold without too much difficulty
so today the topic of the lecture is
going to be this line of the Queens
gambit declined and how people have been
breaking through against Accardo in the
line and how a carro has been holding in
some cases now I did say he's just
started repeating this over and over and
over again pretty much in every game
with black that he has when white goes
for it but I did want to start with a
slightly earlier game and that's because
I wanted to see what this looks like in
a classical version of course all these
latest tournaments have been mostly a
rapid and online and so it has a little
bit of a different feel but in this game
Vishy Anand had the white pieces against
akaru this is a while back I believe and
this was in fact a classical game so
let's see how it went
we have d4 d5 c4 e6 Knight c3
Bishop e7 this is a little bit of an
interesting move order choice by karo in
this game the point I believe is that if
vichy wanted to go for an exchange qgd
all of a sudden this move Bishop g5 is
not a veil
two white and this is generally the the
main main line you can contrast this if
the car had played nine of six instead C
takes D he takes D now Bishop g5 is
potentially a good move so against
Bishop e7 Vichy chose not to go for this
line instead just playing Knight f3
going for some standard stuff Knight f6
and now Bishop f4 and this is I believe
it has a name like the hardwoods attack
but it's just known as basically the
Bishop f4 qgt white the sights to bring
this fish about to f4 voluntarily rather
than the main main line which is I
suppose Bishop g5 it's a little bit more
popular so this line we're gonna take a
look at involves Bishop f4 from white
black goes ahead and castles
we have III now buy white and for a long
time mostly people are playing the moves
c5 in this position and the point is you
just immediately contest the center and
you end up in a position that is going
to have an isolated Queens pawn for
somebody in this specific case with all
of the tension in these four pawns this
is the structure that usually ends up in
that iqp with the Isilon IAM in this
specific scenario it is probably best
for white to take on c5 take on c5 and
eventually take on d5 and you can end up
with an IQ P as stated something like a3
and you have arrived at your IQ P now
for some reason Hikaru has decided that
rather than go for these c5 lines
he is now a main proponent of the move
Knight B to d7 and this is going to be
our starting tabia for today's lecture
this is the position that people with
the white pieces keep going for against
a carro keep getting against akaru and
this is the line that they are really
really testing him in so who here has
been keeping up-to-date with these
tournaments and can guess White's next
move
of course what have white players have
been playing in response to this Knight
bt7 move by Hikaru
so give me a moment to reopen the chat
here so I can actually see what you guys
are saying no answers yet but I will
just reveal to move to you guys the main
line here you can just play normal moves
develop the Bishop tried the pawn felt
the Queen play a three all of these are
potentially playable moves but the most
combative move perhaps is this move c5
and this is in fact the move that most
people are trying here against a card
it's the most popular response to this
Knight bb7 and perhaps this is why
rather than Knight bd7 the most c5 is
really gaining in popularity of course
if you don't play c5 yourself if you
play something like a three for example
then you're gonna get with c5 anyways on
the next turn and all of a sudden these
lines are much less comfortable for you
sort of just a better version for black
being able to recapture on c5 with the
night so this is why c5 by white is
generally the response time be tonight
be d7 so c5 on the board in this game as
well now there are a few different
options here for black in these cases
karu has really been sticking to the
main two tries there is this kind of
tertiary move of 94 but this is not
really something Hikaru has been going
for and it is a little bit funny to be
moving this night around in the center
after white has just sort of claimed all
of this space on the Queen side just to
briefly go over it the game might
continue I could see one take on c3 take
on c3 and then you get the pretty
standard approach of going after this
pawn however due to the time that black
has wasted White has gotten his rook to
a nice square and you might end up in
some pretty complicated lines involving
a c6 here if you play this with the
black pieces so let's not focus too much
on this side line because we are looking
at what Hikaru is doing in these
positions and akaru is either playing
the move Knight h5 or the move c6 and
these are moves with pretty much
identical plans associated with them the
difference of course is that with Knight
h5 black is taking the time to first
remove the f4 Bishop before going for
the main structure in this position with
c6 immediately a car doesn't spend the
time to get rid of the bishop instead
just going for the structure in this
game we're gonna start out with nine h5
this is what a Carter played in the
classical version in the classical game
against the vichy and this is how this
game went now sensible move by white
just Bishop d3
getting the bishop developed we have
Knight takes f4 e takes f4 and now I
would like you guys at home to try and
find carros next two moves this is by
far the most standard way of playing
against this structure that white is
achieved here when white goes for D 4
and C 5 and this is really the major way
to play against these pawns
it's sort of not really okay for black
to just kind of sit tight allow white to
play b4 and just kind of show forever
like this because this is just far too
much space to give your opponent so you
do have to challenge these pawns do you
have to challenge these pawns
yeah and the chat room does have most of
the plan here it's c6 and b6 in this
game a curve actually starts of b6 which
is totally fine because c6 isn't a very
good move here when you play b6 before
c6 this is really the only move you have
to calculate if you're concerned about
it and here Knight b8 is just a good
move for black and this pawn is actually
quite difficult to maintain if you go
for something like this should be 5 you
could just get met with a6 and b5 to
follow if you try to play 95
well you're kind of asking for Bishop d6
and this pawn on c6 is going to fall so
b6 first and white responds with b4 just
defending this pawn now of course the
follow-up for black is to play the move
a5 and this is pretty much remove black
should always be including you want to
have the most tension on these queenside
pawns as possible the move a3 is of
course the response white needs to
support his structure
now see six buy black is pretty much the
only move Mike goes ahead and castles
and now black has a couple choices but
there really it all ends up being the
same Queen c7 now for black and this is
still well within very much known
opening territory so I'd like to ask the
chatroom what's your initial impression
of this position what do you think about
White's chances and White's advantages
because at first glance to my eyes and
perhaps to most eyes it does look as
though white has a very pleasant
position I believe so
does anybody disagree with me there that
white looks to have a pleasant position
uh-huh I'm going to shed my jacket I've
been told it is misbehaving it's a
little bit warm anyways White has two
nights in the closed position that is a
fair assessment a true assessment stuff
almost fell goodness
f-five looks strong looks closed Plex
King site looks a bit weak okay so these
are all pretty interesting thoughts by
the chatroom and normally you would be
correct here so let me show you how
things could just go horribly horribly
wrong for black if black doesn't really
know what he's doing he plays a move
well white plays a move like g3 to
defend this this guy in f4 if black
plays some really awful moves like b5
and a for now all of a sudden I think
white is totally winning in this
position this is just a totally crushing
advantage on the Kings side now for
white with these moves that you talked
about like f5 coming g4 coming and some
kind of a pawn storm while these pieces
are stuck over here on the Queen side
fortunately for black he doesn't have to
play like this and so black is obviously
not doing too bad here it does look as
though White has a nice advantage on the
Kings side but you know the Carver
wouldn't be playing this every game if
it was so bad for black I'm sure
everybody kind of realizes so why isn't
it so bad for black the the question
kind of arises well there's a couple
reasons here number one black is just in
time to get rid of this awful awful
bishop on c8 this is why blacks next
move is kind of the only serious move
that gets played in this position you
cannot leave this guy stuck behind these
awful pawns on the light squares so
Bishop a6 is going to get played other
than that it does still look as though
White has some very nice advantages on a
Kings side so what's the reason black
still isn't worse even after treating
these bishops off well it's because of
this tension on the Queen side due to
this tension on the Queen side black is
always going to be able to open one or
two files kind of
his discretion and with those files
white isn't really gonna be able to
attack on the kingside effectively
whenever you kind of start to launch the
attack you start diverting some pieces
towards the Kings side that's when black
can open the Queen side and sort of
counter punch on that side of the board
and due to that white really only has
one advantage in remaining however he
does still have a structural advantage
and this advantage I believe is why
people keep repeating this line against
akaru
and it's the reason why sometimes they
do actually win some games so that's
this sort of Kings side advantage dealt
with Black has all this counter play on
the Queen side that white does have to
worry about why it sort of has to meet
black on the Queen side rather than go
crazy on the Kings side all the time so
with that in mind what is White's one
structural advantage remaining well it's
the advantage he seized by putting this
pawn on c5 in the first place it's this
slightly slightly weak pawn on the c6
square this pawn is sort of the reason
why it can claim to have some kind of an
edge here it's just going to be a little
bit of a weakness on c6 it's especially
going to be weakness because black
really is going to be forced to at least
open one file on the Queen side and with
at least one file open that means
there's always a small danger of Brooks
and major pieces invading and getting at
this guy from the side or behind there's
also of course a 95 move that is always
going to have to be on blacks mind
specifically in these cases where black
went in Knight h5 followed by Knight
takes at 4 this really increases White's
control over this he 5 squared and so 95
does become a pretty serious idea for
white and that black does have to look
out for so with that in mind let's just
take a look at how this game progressed
how this she ended up an advantage and
and what happened here so rook e1 was
played in the game and this is not the
most popular move most popular move is
actually to capture on
six but rookie one is a perfectly fine
move rookie one believe it or not is
actually making a threat and that threat
is that if you don't do anything look
out
I might actually save my bishop after
having unpinned and then with this
Bishop white can start to have some
ideas on the Kings side once again so a
rookie one kind of making a threat after
Bishop f6 though this she actually
didn't opt for Bishop c2 in this game
it's a playable move but instead just
the simpler King g2 just to solidify and
black did now cave and capture on on d3
Bishop c2 isn't actually all that much
of an edge for white because once again
the King side attack is not going to be
easy to manufacture with all this play
on the Queen side now black just plays
very very sensibly very simple chess and
I think that's a real advantage to
playing this opening with black is the
ideas are I use the word simple I don't
know if simples the correct word but
they're pretty intuitive with black you
know you take a look at this half of the
board and you say okay I can't touch
anything over here
so I play on this half of the board and
so because of that hikaru picks the move
rook fb8
but honestly here there are a variety of
moves that are in my opinion more or
less equivalent for black they all have
the same ideas rook b8 is playable Rick
a7 is definitely playable move trying to
double up you can even play a move like
g6 or h6 here just sort of passing the
turn back to white creating left for
your King you just play simple improving
moves and that is how black goes about
playing this position and the good news
for black is that white cannot really
generate too many very serious concrete
threats here there is one move that
black definitely has to be on the
lookout for and we'll get to that in a
later game I believe but not too many
threats and that black has to worry
about immediately which is why black is
doing mostly okay in these positions
rook F to b8 was played in the game and
this she actually goes for this move Age
4 and this is
at first glance a strong attacking move
you know of issues going for the throat
on the Kings side after further review
though that doesn't actually turn out to
be the case because I I can't really
stress enough all of this Kings side
play is really going to be difficult to
achieve for white due to the threats of
always opening these files on the Queen
side I've said it before I'm gonna
repeat it more often throughout this
lecture because that really really is
important h4 on the other hand is simply
a useful move that's why it was played
it's a useful improving move and the
idea is in any potential end games
you're always gonna have to worry about
this pawn coming to age five baby
trading itself on g6 maybe even going
all the way up the board to h6 and so
it's just putting the pawn here
reminding black hey I can make useful
moves pay attention to my age for pawn I
might come in handy later on in the game
Picaro actually doesn't react to this at
all simply playing the move Queen a7
once again just piling things up on
these potentially open files and now
fishy plays a pretty interesting move
here and at first glance it's pretty
difficult to understand this move so I'm
interested to see if anybody in the chat
can spot the idea behind it so the move
vichy played was 92 and as a small hint
to you guys
92 I believe is only being played
because this Queen moved from c7 over to
a7
so try and find the reason this move
Knight eetu came on the board what was
fishy sinking
in the meantime there's a question from
Mohammed
what's wrong with C takes B 6 & 9 a for
targeting in the c6 pawn and I'll talk
about that in just a moment here the
short answer is you by giving up your c5
pawn it's true that you do have access
to the c6 pawn but you're also giving
this rook access to your b4 pawn and so
it's kind of trading one weakness for
another it's definitely an idea the
black has to keep in mind but it's
really not a normal idea by a by white
okay some answers in the chat now some
people are saying g4 some people are
saying the immediate f5 Knight G 1 to h3
has been suggested as well with a pretty
direct idea
protecting d4 because of the black
bishop otherwise you lose c5 so yeah
these are all some pretty good ideas I'm
not so sure about this line in
particular I guess here let me try to
pass yeah so B takes d5 B takes d5 and
then Knight takes e5 this is a pretty
direct threat and that hikaru is is
actually making here in some cases but
that was probably just cuz I put this
King over here let me make a useful not
a useful move but a better passing move
I don't think that there's any direct
threats on c5 that you need to protects
d4 for d4 yeah for immediately but the
idea is of course yes to one protect d4
but more than protect d4 it's more
eyeing the d4 square at a later date
this pawn didn't need a media protection
but once this pawn leaves the d4 square
then Knight d4 is gonna be a powerful
move so of course nighty to the idea was
that after you know some past move by
black that she does actually want to
play the move f5
I believe and the point is now after E 5
which is the most natural response do
you take c5 Knight takes e5 Knight takes
e5 Bishop takes
now this knight can come into the D
force
and there's actually a ton of lines that
look fairly similar to this that could
arise in the position so 92 I think was
mainly eyeing this d4 square for lines
with f5 and in fact after 92 black was
so concerned with this that he did play
the move g6 just guarding in this f5
square a little bit more now I do also
want to mention that this was
potentially playable for black with the
idea of going for two rooks for the
Queen the problem here is that the two
rooks can't coordinate very well
compared to how well the Queen can
coordinate with with its own pieces for
example the immediate b5 would have been
a problem here for akaru the reason
being there's no comfortable way
comfortable way to respond to this
white's getting this pawn on c6 do you
take c5 now and all of a sudden the
Knights are coming in defending the C
pawns very well and these rooks are
going to struggle actually to stop these
pawns for example if you play a move
like or gate you're already in quite a
bit of trouble 90 d4 c7 is coming Queen
B 5 is coming difficult and difficult
stuff so no imbalance there and said
just g6 and now repeat one by white and
this is sort of what white does a little
bit he just sort of pokes and prods at
black and eventually black caves under
the pressure and has to open up some
some files and that is exactly what
happens in this position so note that
black could have continued kind of
passing with a move like h5 but then is
sort of asking for this 95 idea to come
on the board and once again you see this
point of the night on e 2 and ready to
come back in to the d4 square rook b1 is
also creating sort of another threat
potentially playing this move b5 this is
kind of the one big threat that black
really does have to look out for it if
white ever plays b5 and it turns out to
be a good move and black is really going
to be in
quite quite a bit of trouble I should
say so rook p1 and Hikaru at this moment
decided to take on before and after take
on before take them before he invades
with the Queen to a2 and this is more or
less the the right idea by black in
general you waits for the right moment
to open up a file and then make sure
that when you do open the file it's
going to be more useful to you than it
is to to your opponent
unfortunately for akaru I don't think he
quite calculated this one accurately and
the reason being wishes next move is
quite good at stopping any of cara's
potential ideas Vishu simply plays the
move rook e 2 c1 now if you recall
Mohamed in the chat said why not B takes
c6 and rook takes or and targeting the
c6 pawn when these ideas are actually
starting to become a lot more real
for example if h5 are some passing move
now all of a sudden moves such as b5 and
do become a very serious consideration
with this rook here and preparing
potentially to actually capture on on b6
also moves like 95 are still a problem
so after rook e 2 c1 Caro actually
chooses to open up a second file with
the move b takes c5 and i think it's
this move that really seals the deal for
kuru here into having a significantly
worse position and this is how Hikaru
has been dropping some games in this
opening this is the trickiest part of
the opening determining when it is good
to open up these files on the Queen side
if you time this improperly with the
black pieces that's when you find
yourself suddenly and sort of
mysteriously in a ton of trouble out of
nowhere and this is what happened to
kuru in in this even classical game
where you have plenty of time to you
know think these breaks over encouraged
still somehow seemingly mistimed these
breaks so just to continue the line
and B takes c5 is the natural response
by white we have h5 now on the board
just sealing off in the kingside getting
space for the king as well
and now fishies next move is Knight e5
and this is a move we've been talking
about for quite a while now that Vichy
had plan had planned for quite some time
in this case car does have to capture
this night because once again this
pressure on c6 is too much he chose to
capture with the knight himself either
capture was potentially playable but he
played Knight takes now after F takes
this Bishop came back to g7 and now this
night only two has sort of served his
purpose so we'll see it rerouting
actually back to c3 not super interested
actually in this f4 square it's a little
bit too late in the game to be going for
these kinds of sacrifices
so first rook b6 is an excellent move by
white and this is why I say that B takes
e5 may have been mistimed by Hikaru
because once again you only want to open
these files if it turns out to be
advantageous for you that the file is
open and after the move rook b6 it's
very very clear that vichy
is the one benefiting from this B file
in fact rather than Hikaru and after
rook b6 I think that white may simply
just be winning in this game
strategically I think this is almost
hopeless now for Hikaru already the best
you can kind of hope for is at some
point losing the c6 pawn because that's
the six pawn is gonna die now that white
is really claiming this Queen side space
and somehow trying to hold this endgame
upon down which is really really
unlikely in in my opinion so after rook
b6 I think this game is firmly in fish's
hand and we are twenty-five moves deep
which you could argue is well past the
opening but this early middle game stuff
is very very much part of the opening
play in my opinion so let's back up just
a little bit and examine what went wrong
for a card first of all I didn't want to
talk about this land
come and set it in a little bit more
detail and the issue is that night takes
b6 I think would be played 9 a 4 is
difficult to play in response and if you
just sort of pass for a turn all of a
sudden this open space for your opponent
has become quite useful for him now that
your c5 pawn is gone this is kind of the
the cruncher in your position is the
pawn on c5 it really frees the black
pieces once this pawn disappears so
that's why not C takes b6 in the
meantime though 92 g6 rook a b1 and I
think that a takes b4 was was quite
simply wrong as I've said I believe the
general rule of thumb here for the black
player is you only really touch these
pawns on the Queen side if you're
gaining something very very concrete for
it in this case the Cardo simply did not
gain enough by the opening of these
files and then vichy was able to make
use of them and by making use of them
ended up winning the game so a takes
before may actually be the first misstep
here I think quite honestly the move
Queen back to c7 is is quite good and if
this queen is coming back to c7 then
probably the moved point a7 was a little
bit misguided in in the first place so
Queen a7 perhaps the first inaccuracy by
Hikaru and I think a takes b4 is really
where he started going down the trail of
having a quite bad position in my
opinion here play might have might have
just continued with something like work
to see one with why it's sort of biding
his time I could also go for things like
ninety five and then take c5 f takes d5
Bishop e7 or g7 will pick g7 in this
case and you get sort of similar stuff
but notably Carter has not committed yet
to opening up these Queen side files and
as such he's gonna have a better chance
I believe of defending this position for
sure
so a takes before is perhaps already a
little bit wrong after Queen a to rook e
to see one a huge problem for black is
moves like
rook to a3 simply don't work this move
is actually just a losing move and
perhaps this is sort of what Hikaru
missed is that moves like rook to a3
here are just not going to be playable
now why is that well there's actually a
tactic here for white a very very very
unusual tactic so white to move and win
in this case I say it's a tactic but
it's less about immediate material gain
and more about just highlighting the
awkwardness of these black major pieces
so weight to move and win white queen
and c7 well because it defends for one
the c6 pawn for two the e5 square and
it's Queen on the a7 was honestly
blocking out the rook on a excellent
question though
excellent question
Knight c3 has been suggested twice
Webster actually does have the correct
move with Queen d1 the problem with
Knight c3 is I believe actually the move
B takes c5 is playable for for black and
if you continue with B takes e5 all of a
sudden wreck b2 b3 is going to appear on
the board and this is just some some
craziness but not winning for white the
move is in fact Queen to d1 and this is
just entirely unfortunate for Hikaru
here if this were to appear on the board
for example the threat is of course to
play rook to c2 trapping the Queen and
the other threat is stuff like Knight c3
coming in you have to play something
like Rik 8/8 and now unfortunately once
again the move b5 is the threat that
wins the game tactically can't really
force the win of the Queen in this case
but b5 is just going to be absolutely
crushing just as an example line B takes
e5 okay one Queen B to B takes c6 and
this Knight has nowhere to go
really Knight b6 for example back over
here c7 and already things are starting
to to drop before black so I think in
general this idea of Queen a7 was where
her car was started kind of down the
rabbit hole of of a misguided plan so in
general you don't really want the Queen
in front of the rooks like this just in
chess and specifically in this case it
turned out not to be such a great idea
as well and so this is where it all
really went wrong for our car in my
opinion and then especially after uxie
won the move B takes c5 is just being a
little bit too friendly I think even a
move like b5 might have been a slightly
better try the point being now this B
file stays closed for the moment black
does still have control over the a file
and maybe a cargo can actually seriously
consider trying to hold this in this
position although it doesn't appear to
be the most pleasant thing of all time
in my opinion
okay but let's see how the game finished
for you guys I'm kind of robbing you
finish Rick p6 came on the board rook
over to c8 Knight c3 Queen back to a7
now this she just totally dominates the
B file and with coming up to be four now
and the knight does come into a four in
the b6 square is just dropping Queen d8
and now Rick a6 is a fantastic winning
move by the former world champion if you
capture this just the Queen comes in
okay it doesn't do anything because this
e6 pawn drops so King g7 instead and now
Rick p7 and this is just deadly Queen e2
was a little bit of a funny move maybe
by fishy stuff like nine p6 is already
crushing but I mean Queen e2 is a fine
move it so Queen e2 G for Queen back to
a six now that's this has sort of been
rectified on the King side Queen g8 and
a p6 and we see now that she taking the
exchange and expertly navigating any
complications occur could have had on
the Kings side by checkmating his
opponent first so what's the moral of
this game the moral of this game is that
while white doesn't have too many
immediate like crushing attacks or
threats on anywhere on the board
White's role in this opening isn't
really to go for those because those
don't simply exist as I as I just said
what's role in this type of opening is
to sort of poke and make little threats
in the black position like Oh kind of
hinting maybe I'm gonna play a 5 maybe
I'm gonna play 95 maybe I'm gonna play
b5 and at some point black is going to
try and counter punch and say hey you
have gone too far making these threats
now's my chance to open the a a file
open the B file and get at you on on the
Queen's side and it makes for a really
interesting game which is why I'm not
super unhappy that
the card keeps repeating it and people
with the white pieces keep repeating it
against him as well in this case Queen
a7 was a little bit of a misguided idea
Nakara opened up the files at the wrong
moment I ended up getting crushed now I
actually want to jump to a game of Levon
Aronian skipping a little bit ahead here
as we spend a lot of time on that first
game
Levon of course played against a Caro a
number of times in Milan Doris rattling
Doris ABI rapid challenge that concluded
a couple weeks ago on chess 24 and her
cargo faced Levon in the quarterfinals I
believe where he did end up defeating
Levon and moving on to the semi-finals
but not without facing Levon in this
exact variation a number of times
actually so why don't we jump in take a
look at how Levon decided to handle it
we have d4 to start Knight f6 c4 e6 9 f3
d5 Knight c3 Bishop e7 Bishop f4 castles
and III so once again we get to our
starting tabia after the move Knight B
to d7 just what a car has been playing
recently we have the move c5 and now
rather than go for this night h5 and
Knight takes a four line in this game
Macario actually does play tomb of c6
he's been playing both of these moves
kind of interchangeably the move h3 came
on the board for LaVon highlighting that
you know you're not going to get a
second chance at my bishop giving it a
flight square and now b6 does come on
the board B 4 a 5 a 3 this is really
just the main way of playing for black
in this position h6 was a very
interesting choice by Hikaru here the
point being if you played Bishop a6
immediately white is going to capture
this Bishop and after rook takes just
simply Castle is one of the main
variations and so with h6 black is
claiming he makes a useful waiting move
and now after the move Bishop d3 black
has the go-ahead to play Bishop a6
claiming that white has lost a tempo if
he's going to capture in this Bishop
White's in this case agreed with LaVon
simply castling opting not to capture
and now a cargo plays the move Queen to
c8 perhaps defending these light scores
even more and now of course the key
difference in this game versus the last
game is this Bishop is still on the
board and with this Bishop still on the
board
this Queen can not come to the most
natural square on c7 and this is sort of
the downside to leaving the Bishop alive
so that's why we see the slightly more
awkward Queen c8 to b7 in this game now
LaVon does something very very
interesting that we haven't seen yet
from from the white side and the reason
for this is that as I said generally
black is the one trying to decide the
absolute best moment to open up files on
the Queen side in this game
LaVon tries to press that issue daring
black to open the files immediately
perhaps before black is is really ready
to do so and so the move Knight a four
came on the board by LaVon and I quite
like this idea to my knowledge it is a
novelty that LaVon has played here so
I'd like to ask you guys at home how
would you respond to this with the black
pieces would you sort of cave and take
on beef or maybe take on c5 or play b5
or would you sort of stand true and
ignore this night on a for play move
like Queen b7 for example how do you
want to respond to this
probably not the best title for the
chess class given his opening play today
well mark we're looking at how it kind
of went wrong for black in some cases
we're looking at some of his draws as
well if we find the time I'm starting
off with two losses for a Carew which is
probably a bit unfair for him as he does
have quite a number of really nice draws
in this game as well
this isn't text alive Anil edy Ridley
says b5 Bishop takes d3 has been
suggested Bishop b5 is an interesting
move didn't really consider that one
exchanged the bishop in b5 then b5 b5
probably eight takes P so if you do play
the move b5 of course some of you might
have just not mentioned it but you you
really can't play this move before
trading off the bishops so Bishop takes
Queen takes in b5 is going to be a
pretty interesting idea here for black
the problem is after Knight c3 you
really are committing to quite a lot
here with this pawn on d5 black does
have to be very very very cautious now
and the movie has to be cautious of for
example if he passes a rook lands on p1
he passes again B takes a five or it
takes a five and a four this is now
always going to be a threat in the
position for white and the threat of is
of course to remove the c6 pawn in
giving white a passed pawn on c5 now
immediately that isn't a problem because
black doesn't have to make two nothing
moves in a row but it is sort of leaning
towards playing the immediate a takes b4
and it takes b4 and this I believe is
sort of what Levon Aronian wanted he
wanted a card to open up the position as
quickly as possible before he was ready
to really dominate the a file and I
think here black is not really going to
be totally comfortable the reason for
that being he has no compensation for
the c6 pawn the c6 pawn is just going to
be a stark weakness in this position now
isn't enough for white to win I'm not so
sure but isn't it is it an advantage I
think definitely and that's just because
black does not have the dominance from
the a file that he really looks to
achieve before
anything's up so in the game Accardo
actually chooses the move Queen b7
instead that's not to say taking and
playing b5 is wrong but Hikaru does
choose to play Queen b7 instead and I do
think this leaves black with a little
bit more flexibility to play for more of
a direct equality than having this
contested a file with this weakness on
c6 sort of persisting now in the game
there is actually finally the really
interesting idea of taking on b6
available to LaVon it was not played in
the game and I really am not such a huge
fan of this move you should really only
be playing this move if you can really
directly and get an attack on the c6
pawn because once you take on b6 there's
sort of no going back this Bishop is now
active this night is going to be active
and all of black's pieces sort of spring
to life the second this pawn disappears
but instead simply Queen c2 I think is
the better move is the more principled
approach now after the Queen has sort of
committed to moving black does capture
on d3 we see Queen takes T 3 and now
Hikaru goes for the move Knight to e4
and I actually am not the hugest the
hugest the biggest fan of this move in
general buying kuru this is another
advantage to not playing Knight h5 and
Knight takes F for your knight does have
access to this efore square but I think
more relevant is actually it's sort of
trying to bring more pieces over to to
the Queen side I think this sort of but
should have been priority number one for
Hikaru for example if you play a move
like b5 in this case Knight c3 now all
of a sudden you do have time to play
something like a 6 and rook over to a8
and now this dominance on the a file can
sort of be achieved by by black once
again though you do have to be a
slightly wary of these ideas with a 4 to
follow but I don't think they're quite
not quite working here just yet for
LaVon with stuff like B for being very
very reasonable
this is likely Wyatt karube didn't
choose to go for this though just
because LaVon has been so cagey on this
Queen site here daring blacks sort of to
play this b5 move 94 though and LaVon
responds very very naturally with rook F
to be one just super preparing for the
opening of these files a takes before
now was a Cara's choice a takes b4 b5
does come on the board and now Knight c3
by LaVon challenges this knight on e4
and so f5 by Hikaru was his choice and
f5 is is is a little bit much in my
opinion it's it's quite a lot to give
away here perhaps simpler for a car
would have been to keep things as level
as possible not committing to this f5
move and just taking on on c3 now you
know we can sort of just pass the time
play Bishop d8 even if we're worried
about our a v square and sort of gopher
for this a five counter play after the
move f5 I think the issue for akaru is
the one simply avoids this trade and
it's it's now sort of impossible to find
counter play with the black pieces f5
removes any ideas of playing the move e5
in this position and because of that all
that really remains is the a file which
still stands contested and other than
that black has simply no active play so
with f5 black truly cements this night
on the e4 square but gives up any chance
of active play which I think was a
Cara's mistake in this case the move
Bishop f6 came on the board but now
LaVon is happy to play his next move
hopefully you guys at home can see it
it's the same idea connected with 92 go
ahead and take a guess for yourselves
I'm not gonna wait though the move of
course is 95 this move by LaVon aims to
use the d4 square with this e to night
once a
this is a really key move that white
times in order to make it good for him
to recapture it sort of with the pawn
and play this move Knight d4 trying to
just sort of overwhelmed black
immediately in this case well I can not
actually capture this night because 94
is just simply winning they're so nice
five is played instead now LaVon does
actually capture on d7 we see Queen
takes d7 and I'd like you to try and
find lavon's next maneuver here try and
find lavon's maneuver what do you think
he played in this position in particular
King Lear is asking when I'm going to
make an effort to try and get a feed a
title probably not until there are feed
eight tournaments that I can play in
again
why would black play b5 I presume the
white knight wants to reroute anyways
well it's it's all down to that pressure
Inlet that LaVon was putting on the on
the Queen's side perhaps if black didn't
play b5 white really would start
thinking about playing an active move
like b5 himself and other things of that
that nature we can back up to that
position though and sort of examine it
okay
Knight c1 going for d5 I assume you mean
II five Manny yeah he corrected himself
and that's actually totally correct here
Bishop d6 Bishop d6 is actually a really
good move here for for white but it's
it's sort of just a single tempo it
doesn't help too much but yeah the move
LaVon went for is actually this move
Knight c1 but the idea of 93 and 95 to
follow believe it or not though LaVon
actually has much better in this
position LaVon is actually I believe I'm
just just winning in this position with
a better move and nobody so far has
suggested the move that is quite good
for LaVon winning might be an
exaggeration but it is really really
good for for white
so nobody sees the winning idea Rick
a5g4 no unfortunately these are not the
moves your k5 black is quite happy to
take this and this a pond I think is
going to prove to be more of a weakness
than an asset here with the rook on a6
being a block hater that's almost
impossible to get rid of and you can try
and do something like this but good luck
playing all those moves without hanging
that pun g4 I think is just a little bit
too much this pawn hangs immediately for
example but the move is in fact going to
be Bishop e5 which great wolf has now
put into the chat room excellent job
there and the reason this is so good for
white it's once again it bears black
into capturing when once again 94 it's
just going to be the most monstrous
night I've ever seen in my life and
that's just going to be dominating the
black position and if you don't capture
play a move like Queen f7 for example or
even Knight f7 let's say well then white
is going to be happy to capture here and
play a move like Knight f4 and these are
now all weaknesses that you have to
contend with on the Kings side of the
board and this is going to be quite
relevant in the game as well this is
just simply too many weaknesses here so
of course Queen f7 is an attempt to not
allow these things and in response to
this Bishop takes f6 is perhaps playable
but even better is the move Queen d1
with the point being you can't both
guard this Bishop and guard the 8th file
play might continue 94 takes takes rook
a1 takes takes when all of a sudden
these things are going to be pretty
devastating here if you go back this way
I might just capture playing out of 4
and it's difficult to guard all of the
squares available to this white White
Queen and this is just sort of sort of
monstrous so I think this would have
actually been slightly better for LaVon
going for this nice move Bishop e5 in
connection with saying there are too
many threats for you to deal with in
this
understandably LaVon did not go for this
though it was a rapid game difficult to
find these complex ideas it's that
playing Knight c1 now we have nine of
seven Queen over to c3 is guarding the
a1 squared preparing to try and capture
the a file eric fe8 was played in the
game and now simply 93 going for a 5 as
previously stated and once again this is
the problem with playing f5 Caro is
still trying to get a 5 in but he just
never has enough without this pawn
sometimes able to step 2 to f6 if needed
and in it is in fact going to be white
taking control of this square Queen b7
was played and now rook b3 is a nice
idea by white pointing out that he is
able to double rook a4 was played in the
game and this is really the turning
point in the game rook-a for is sort of
admitting that okay black has done wrong
here and because white was able to take
control of the the a file honestly
though it's a little bit too late for
Carew to to do anything else he sort of
has to go for this of course the idea
now for LaVon is the instant that rook
lands on the square
he simply captures it be tix now Rick a
three block hitting the pawn and it's
the same reason why your ak5 was a bad
move for white this pawn is just more of
a weakness than it is a a boon Queen b5
was played in the game which is a pretty
sensible move Queen c2 just piling up on
this pawn rook a8 now and now
LaVon plays a very very nice idea which
I guess you guys at home might want a
chance to find I'm gonna spoil it though
for you so if you want to try to find it
pause your video now the move is Bishop
c7 and the idea is we just stick this
guy on a5 and all of a sudden it's
nearly impossible to defend this pawn
Carter tried Bishop d8 to defend it but
Bishop a5 anyways if you take this guy I
take here and you are pinned along the a
file so Bishop back to f6 and then LaVon
goes up this a pawn and I don't want to
spend too much more time in this game
this game went on
for years and years and years there was
complex stuff on the kingside that
happens and at the end of the day they
ended up in this end game which should
be good for whites and then black
sacrifices the bishop and we get rook
and Bishop versus rook which LaVon
somehow did manage to win in this game
with this being in the final position
forgive me for not going through all 118
moves but the character of the game was
really decided by this plan the a file
and this is so often what happens in
these games now I wanted to take a look
at one more game for the end of the show
here that was once again played between
Levon Aronian and akaru Nakamura I
believe this is the the game I wanted to
go over it's not this is the game I
wanted to go over so in this last game
we'll see what it looks like when it
actually goes about four black when
black does manage to take over this a
file and sort of succeeds in his opening
ideas so let's jump right into it we
have d4 and of course our starting tabia
is chiefed without too much delay Knight
bt7 here and c5 once again in this game
once again here Kuro does not opt for
the knight age 5 line choosing a c6
instead and then h3 b6 B 4 a 5 a 3 is
all standard stuff and he chose to
repeat this h6 move once again trying to
dare white into playing Bishop d3 trying
to sort of save the tempo over the main
variation and now Levon goes clean to c1
which is a pretty interesting move and
this is perhaps the reason this h6 move
is not played quite so often for for
black the point of this move is that a
few kind of backtrack and play Bishop a6
no well I can actually take this rook a6
look yeah ever takes a6 and play this
move b5 and after takes c6
and now you are sort of in for a world
of hurt the move be for has to be played
but this night simply jumps to be five
now tonight c5 but the problem is my
queen is in a very good position to sort
of support these things and 95 is is
genuinely a a peace sacrifice for black
so queen c1 is a very devious move
actually making a threat and that's why
we see the move Bishop e7 by Hikaru
Bishop e2 was played in the game queen
c8 now castles Bishop a6 but black has
sort of given this tempo back by playing
Bishop e7 followed by Bishop a6 and now
LaVon plays the move rook to e1 we see
queen bee 7 by caro rook over to be one
now is eyeing this file
probably threatening move like be takes
a5 with threats here and so that's why
we see now that this rook has stepped
off of the a file and kuru is confident
that he can make use of the a file
himself so he plays the move a takes b4
of course a takes before is played in
response if rook takes b4 here be on the
lookout actually for the simple captures
and queen to c8 the point being if you
capture here your rook is hanging and if
you don't capture here b takes e5 it's
gonna be quite good so a takes instead
and now Bishop takes e to is very
natural Bishop takes e to and now black
to move here black to move I think you
guys should be able to find blacks next
move it's not like a crazy move or
anything but it is the sensible
continuation of this opening what is
this opening all about it's about the a
file that move is your K 7 of course you
just double the rooks it's that simple
rook c2 now by white is perhaps once
again hinting at some stuff like C takes
b6 or b5 with support for the C pawn so
the Carter then plays the move b5 not
wanting to open up his Queen to attack
of course
and now after 92
white is aiming for this square but rook
f28 comes on the board
g4 by whites and now Bishop d8 by black
is is nice just stopping any Knight a5
ideas before they get started and now
it's clear that the black is the one
firmly in command with this control over
the a file g4 is you know trying to
pretend you can do something on the
Kings side but if black does get control
the a file as I've said before it's more
than enough counter play on the Queen
side to compensate for any King side
attack that white can generate so let's
quickly go through see how the game went
Bishop g3 they should see seven and now
LaVon goes for f4 and this was his big
idea this Bishop d8 move yes controlling
a5 also coming to c7 to support
potential e5 pushes as as well for black
rook a3 was now played taking advantage
of his a file King up to g2 now work 8
to a7 prepares to treble on the AF file
as the aster says I don't know why he
says treble instead of triple but I
would repeat anything that man said
Knight be three Queen over to a8
trebling Knight a5 now was lavon's idea
the point being
and this rook gets a little bit stranded
but Hikaru had seen this coming and was
actually just planning an exchange
sacrifice here which is a perfectly
playable playable move in general rook 3
to a6 would have been the safer option
not allowing this Knight a5 business and
the game would have just continued here
this is also fine for black but quitting
8 Knight a5 and we do see rook takes c3
takes on a5 and takes an a5 and so black
sacrifices the exchange in exchange for
controlled the a file still the only
open file on the board pointing out that
the rooks aren't very useful if they
can't get to the open file and this past
beep on which is protected and quite
nice in the game Bishop e1 was played
night up to e4 is a really nice square
for the knight as well another advantage
to taking off this knight on c3 your
accede to b3 or gay to is check mr. Rick
blocked rec a1 b1 or k2 p2 okay one
rupee 1 or k2 and the game was
agreed to a draw so this is really what
black is striving for in this type of
opening you open up the a file when you
want to not when white wants you to open
up the AF file and that's really the
character of this opening it's it's this
battle between the player with the white
pieces and the player with the black
pieces to get control of these open
files for for themselves so white tries
to force black to open them advantageous
Leifer for white and black tries to open
them at kind of at his leisure whenever
he's ready to firmly take control of the
files for example in this game the key
move that Carter sought to open up the
file was this move rook b1 when the
circuit vacates the file car has said
now's my chance he gave up on the a file
I should take it while I can and it's
exactly what he did ended up drawing
this game quite comfortably I think that
is just about going to do it for this
lecture hopefully you guys have a more
solid understanding of this opening that
your card keeps repeating if you guys
are following any of these awesome
online tournaments live hopefully you'll
be able to understand a little bit more
the next time this appears on the board
what exactly is going on here this has
been chess openings explained and we are
going to have a tactics class happening
on Twitch directly after this so if
you're watching live be sure to head
over to the twitch channel for it that's
other than that that does conclude the
lecture thank you all so much for
joining me and I will see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you